we followed the road north through
ethiopia's highlands on the road that
leads to tigre
but the country's maps may need
rewriting
for this pot marked track leads to war
in the region of amhara everyone who is
able is expected to fight including
middle and high school students who were
called up last month
they've joined forces with the national
army in a fight to the death with the
rebellious state of tigre
the two sides massing their forces and
trading blows on lands adjacent to the
country's central highway there are
thousands of troops in this area close
to the front men women
many of them very are and it looks like
they are preparing for battle
further south in the ethiopian capital
the country's prime minister abi ahmed
was sworn in for a new five-year term
he took power as a progressive and
award-winning peacemaker but his
premiership has been dogged by war with
the party which runs tigre the tplf
abby calls them cancer
[Applause]
their political dispute has shaken the
nation and the evidence was all around
this tplf tank was taken out by a drone
said these preoccupied ethiopian
soldiers
our guides from a local militia then
took us up a mountain to a village
called uruga and asked us to inspect the
damage
the tagrayians held this place for three
or four days they said and incinerated
its clinic and grain mill a local farmer
took us for a tour
why do you think they did that that's
really where you know
that's when they were yesterday
what do you want to happen to the tplf
what do you want to happen to the people
of tigray
sometimes
most of the men here are prepared to
fight
and we were led to the center of the
village where they sat under an olive
tree clutching their weapons
they call themselves sharit la bashoch
a militia of sorts and a symbol of mass
mobilization in amhara
their leader says they'll die for their
nation and their land
etopia
human rights groups say atrocities have
been committed on both sides in this
conflict although the tplf has denied
all allegations in places like aruga
most residents in the village managed to
flee the attack
but there were some who were too old to
run
an 80-year-old called imam tafera was
shot at the door of his home
and we found his son
standing at his father's grave
tefera told us he is ready to fight
the consequence of a civil war that has
nothing to do with civility
john sparks sky news in amhara